former member of US military
intelligence is helping fight one of the
deadliest terror groups in Africa he is
a pioneer in the US military's use of
drones that expertise is now being used
in Somalia fight against al-shabaab the
Al qaeda-linked Terabithia is in the
Somali capital of Mogadishu Mogadishu
with a look at the anti-terror strategy
Deborah good morning good morning the
threat of unpredictable violence is
ever-present here al-shabaab's Reach is
vast and they are one of the most
organized and dangerous of Africa's
militant groups al-shabaab no longer
controls the crumbling city of Mogadishu
but it has still been able to wreak
havoc with its relentless bombing
campaigns their weapon of choice has
been the vehicle bomb like the one used
with devastating effect on October the
14th killing over 500 people in the
capital we have repeatedly been told
that al-shabaab has eyes and ears
everywhere that they blamed easily into
local communities a quiet street like
this may not look menacing but it can
turn nasty in an instant
former US military intelligence officer
Brett Vella Kovac wants to change that
he has donated commercial drones to the
Somali police force and is training them
to use the technology in the fight
against al-shabaab when they go into
different areas to clear parts that are
under Shabaab control they will actually
fly those drones low and in front of
them to look out for roadside bombs
another al-shabaab tactic is to plant
one bomb and as the first responders
arrive they detonate another killing
everyone who is rushed to help the
investigators will actually go out and
they'll fly our drones and they'll make
sure that the area is safe for first
responders to come into the body
intelligence has told us that al-shabaab
continues to practice its bomb-making
skills over and over again until they
get it right and in this Sal Shabaab
footage they test one of their bombs on
an African peacekeeping convoy drone
technology could help swart attacks like
these
significantly alters the way they could
actually do constituent work exactly I
mean imagine walking into a situation
where you don't know if the people at a
in a house or a compound have weapons if
they have explosives but if you can see
from the air what you're about to walk
into that changes the game
all she Bob's bombs are increasingly
more complex and more powerful this
simple drone technology could provide a
much-needed boost for the overworked
under-resourced Somali counterterrorism
units Nora really interesting Debra pata
in Mogadishu thank you